head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts the
whistleblowing involves a crisis of
conscience they have to weigh their
loyalty to the organization versus to
the public interest and and and I think
that you know with the story that we're
we're going to talk about here tonight
with these airline pilots actually St
Clair did you see that video this week
it was just like an explosion it's it's
just everything's sort of been festering
and getting to this point and it just
blew open like this little C of Pilots I
did a spaces with her and I would say
about 70% of airline pilots are more
conservative and about 80 to 90% of the
ticket agents are more liberal so you
know these PE these people inside the
airlines you know they they're they're
they're begging me to do something about
it you know expose these buses are
dropping people off so it's remarkable
it's a remarkable scene I mean I was
cornered in in the airport by these uh
Airline workers it was like the the Sami
stop the Soviet Union don't don't get
Whispering I don't want to be seen with
you but the buses are pulling up in 20
minutes so that that's that's a new
phenomena and and they could lose their
jobs and then one of the one of the
people has a husband and she doesn't
want her husband to know that she's
talking to me you know what I mean these
are these are these are incredible
moments that I've never experienced
before I think it has a lot to do with
uh this growing realization I suppose
it's very
simple when I what I've talked about for
the past several years if you keep your
head down and keep your mouth shut and
keep working for companies because your
argument is I have a family I have
children to feed you there's a lot of
people who are like Tim you don't have
kids you don't understand how hard it is
I can't lose my job how will my kids eat
the attitude you know my attitude is
like you are absolutely correct that
does not change the fact you are
standing with Satan yeah cuz people
not everyone can grow food you can get a
vertical little Garden in your kitchen
but like if you've known for a decade
that you could get a vertical Farm in
your kitchen and grow a little bit of
crops for your kids to eat and you
haven't done it yet you might want to
question your sanity well it's it's this
it's this to all the people out there
who say you know I would not blow the
whistle I'm seeing like you know James
is mentioned a lot of people are
stepping forward now more people are
coming forward I think the point is
they're realizing this point and this
point is
did you think when and this is
figurative or literal depending on how
you want to take it if you're a person
of Faith or not did you think the devil
when offering you a deal would only
offer you luxury instead of necessity
it's it's an absurd proposition a deal
with the devil isn't how would you like
an infinity pool in a golden statue of
yourself because people don't care about
those things the deal with the Devil is
always how would you like your children
to have full bellies every night serve
me on your knees and I will will make
sure your children are fed yeah and so I
understand the terrifying nature of the
the the fan deal but so many people when
I when I heard this from Owen Shroyer
about the prison guards I'm like those
guards saying I know your work I like
what you do I'm just doing my job what
they are telling you is I signed the
devil's contract I think a lot of people
though are it's like Eric Maxis now
we're talking it's like acid in your
heart and it's like I want I need to
keep my job well you can America says
you can keep your job and go to hell and
and but my children and again I don't
have children and I can't fully
empathize but I I would say your
children are going to respect you you're
they going to respect you more if you if
you do the right thing maybe not I mean
I'll be honest like I'm not I'm not
sitting here to pretend that it's it's
easy in any way it's probably the
hardest imaginable thing again I don't
have kids I I respect that and your kids
may not understand see I think it's the
hardest imaginable thing but you're
stronger having gone through it I think
your kids will respect you when they're
older and they fully understand the
sacrifices made I mean when I look back
at the founding fathers we're talking
about wealthy dudes who had literally no
reason to revolt no no no hold on like
there's a lot of grievances they listed
but these were grievances as leaders and
they were upset about what was being
done to their communities and the future
for their children when I said they had
no reason I'm saying these guys could
have kissed the pinky ring of the king
and been wealthy and wanted for nothing
but they saw that the crown was abusive
they saw that the regulars were abusive
they saw Farmers being killed and they
said we will not sit idly by in our
luxury and comfort we will risk our
sacred honor our treasure our blood our
families and they did and that is
inspiration that is respect man Ben
Franklin lost basic what are you going
to say I was going to say the thing is
they believed that there was a better
option for their children and so this
argument of like well I have kids I need
to provide for them is completely
reasonable I understand that fear on the
other hand if you are helping a company
that is ultimately preaching a world
that is destructive what are you leaving
for your children to grow up in I just I
I like I just to hammer and reiterate
the reason why I think James O'Keefe is
is seeing so many people stand up is
that they've realized when the the this
is the deal with the devil of course
it's going to help your family of course
your kids will eat food and you are
scared about what happens the the the
the the deal will never just be to give
you a convertible because think about
the bargaining power of of of again
figurative or literal the Devil comes to
you with a bar with a deal what Leverage
does he have to say I can give you a
Ferrari or an infinity pool none you're
going to be like I'm going to give you
my soul for wealth what does that mean
to me then he goes and says your
children will die unless you sign in
blood my contract they say I will I will
do anything you say that's right that's
right I mean it's that Elon kind of
rejected that premise a few weeks ago
didn't he with with Disney he you're
blackmail me with money and I think
that's that's the person go yourself
that's the personification of this
movement I mean
whistleblowing you know it's it's uh uh
people people going against the the idea
of a social contract people inside the
corporation the presence of the outside
on the inside these people are i' i'
again Tim I've never seen anything like
this I mean I would I would be perusing
my DMs for a weekend I might get a
couple interesting I work inside this
company but it's
just like like clockwork and I think
it's Elon I think it's X I think it's
the platform people I can't believe that
people in the government are just
sliding into my DMs I'm like dude at
least use signal or something but
they'll just DM me on Instagram be like
I work for the DHS that's good you know
why why is that because people are no
longer scared right there the the
mentality is we have broken the dam we
are winning we are winning culturally
and I will no longer serve evil do you
think any of it has to do with the
timing of the election like there's one
year left might as well come forward now
I don't think it's there's one year left
isn't that crazy I don't just I don't
think you just mean about Biden's
presidency I think who knows what I mean
a year away or a year and 3 months away
no something is happening it might be
the Elon thing Elon speech to Disney
it's a Confluence of events um but the
IBM story we did i' I've never seen the
CEO of IBM there was was on tape saying
some things he shouldn't have said about
Asians and then he gets on an all staff
Call with IBM he says no this James
o'keef video do not respond to the video
do not give a reaction everyone and then
that was leaked to me by 10 people so
and they can't fire they can't fire
they they can whacka all one person but
if you have 118 leaks it's actually
impossible for HR with an IBM to do
anything about it your ship is just
thinking your ship is I mean your
exactly you got water coming out of this
hole that hole there's nothing they can
do yeah you know if when a Dam breaks it
usually is pretty destructive and when
like a Sie if you Sie a balloon and it
pops that's essentially the pretty
powerful explosive force seemingly do
you are you concerned with what might
happen if these operations rupture from
the inside or I think it's happening and
I've been thinking about this I'm kind
of a victim of my own success I'm trying
to figure out how to manage this dam
breaking and and how it can be leveraged
for for for good I mean it's always been
a crisis of conscience with the
Whistleblower because you have to betray
betray your your colleagues your
corporation your employer for the
Public's right to know the information
and now it seems people are so fed up so
fed up like with this immigration thing
I was just talking about here people
getting you know refugees everyone's a
refugee crossing the border here's a
free airplane ticket no security go fly
somewhere and now you can vote and buy a
gun I mean it's just I mean it's so it's
so crazy it's like an SNL satire that
perhaps the American people saying I'm
I'm I'm I can't do this Pilots saying
and talking to Ashley you should talk to
Ashley too she's inundated with Pilots
are they going to stop Flying the
airplanes I I remember back when the
mandates were were on Pilots were also a
lot a lot of Pilots are starting to
stand up I think what we are seeing over
the past several years culturally we are
winning more and more people I mean
simply look at Donald Trump's polling
okay Trump is not a saint Trump is not
your hero but a singular reflection a a
a a Nexus point of the sentiment of the
people people who did not vote in 2020
swing heavily towards Donald Trump that
indicates that a lot of people not and
and again I'm not saying Trum saying but
a lot of people are apprised of what is
happening to this country and the world
and this is also indicative of more
whistleblowers more people stepping up
more people refusing to play ball in in
the machines game it feels like in a way
it feels like people that are like I've
had enough of this system let's let's
expose it and call it out it's kind of
like that moment in Indiana Jones where
he's about to take the idol off the
thing but they don't have a bag of sand
to put on they just take the idol like
they're like I'm done with it I just
can't imagine being a like 18-year-old
voter this year right when you're 10 to
like Middle School whatever life is
pretty pretty good gas press down
Trump's in office then you hit 14 Co
Biden says all kinds of crazy stuff he
falls down constantly we're on the brink
of war in like three different places
and then you're 18 and you're like I
don't want to vote for this guy again
this is bad well the majority of
whistleblowers in in the 20th century I
think suffered an obscurity and and as
Jeffrey wgan is a great example that was
a 60 Minutes guy who blew the whistle on
nicotine big tobacco and his marriage
ended his mortgage ended he was he was
sued he had Security death threats but
if but if if this the verse effect is
now happening it's not the Whistleblower
who is being targeted and subjected
there's this weird inversion that is
happening it's the it's the guy who's
the CEO of IBM who's now who's now being
subjected to online comments and who's
facing pressure so there's this
inversion in power and the social
pressures are actually like with Dei
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net